you get this sort of side of the the
martial arts family growing up
training all the time but you're also in
in real which is a crazy place and and
the lifestyle that you had going on
there
which you which you talk about here
going to the book
rio is like new york city and bangkok
combined
it is a turbulent whatever you want
whenever you want it
mix of sex crime drugs nature
and beach culture although we lived in a
nice apartment in copacabana
rio is not like la there's not a rich
town like beverly hills and then a poor
one like compton
they are combined one minute you're in
beverly hills
and the next you turn down a side street
and you are in compton
as a kid i developed street smarts from
gang bangers to fighters to the high
society matrons
to the surfers to the most beautiful
girls in ipanema
i wanted to understand all of it i would
often ditch school and just walk around
rio
i had normal rounds that i made through
the city
so you're kind of living this kind of
crazy turbulent
turbulent lifestyle yes and you're just
drawn to that
very much because you know in my house
i was the youngster and the halls horion
and helson was eight nine and ten years
older than me
so when i about 11 12 i
like to hear what they say to keep up
with you know
so for me when i go home
i was listening and learning with those
smart guys you know
and when i go to the street i don't want
to stay with the
10 11 year olds which are just thinking
about
silly things i was just walking with the
older guys talking about things i hear
my brothers talk
and the guys say hey this kid is not
it's not so he's not what he's saying so
i was trying to be very
you know compatible with the higher
level
street guys i said i see on the street
so that's kind of put me in a
in a very uh soft
place because i have to be smart i have
to be
very much solid with them
show no fear show so to be able to walk
with them to be able to get in the car
and go some
surf somewhere so i was there to just
show them i can handle you know so i was
just
give me a mission i will do you know
sometimes the guys they they
want to smoke pot for example and nobody
wants to go in the dealer's spot because
they all
want to afraid of the cops i was 12
11. i said no i can go with my trunks
i can go up and down hide the thing and
nobody gonna see it so
i was just being like the kid which
helps the older guys to get what they so
i was just
doing things regardless of right or
wrong i just try to keep myself in a
position
to be respected from the the boys on the
hood you know and
and being like a street guy not exactly
a a spoiled kid which
forbidden to play on the street or
something so i was just
taking care of my life as a i was a girl
i was 18 19 and i was just 12. you know
and you ended up kind of running with a
gang of kids
oh yeah i mean for me it was a
demonstration of courage demonstration
of
being tough you know it was not about
doing right or wrong it's about be
keep be able to keep with the boys and
be respected in the hood as a
as a as a guy who can not gonna flick
you know we're not gonna
so that's kind of gives me a good sense
of
be be part of a team which is
a tough team the guys they're all
fighters they all tough kids they're all
you know very very much
born to just do trouble and things
and i always start to growing up a
little bit i start to see
all those values i learn on the street
are not values i should take
in my life as a if i want to grow up and
represent what i want so
my mission my passion for the family was
take me away from that
dark side of being just doing problems
and
start to become more an athlete and
becoming
completely focused on my life as a
representative of jiu-jitsu
but with a sense of base and sense of
you know
i i'm not gonna let my friends down and
i'm always good
to be a solid you know no matter if he's
going
you know if he's a good thing if it's
the wrong thing i want to be part of
and be trusted by my friends so that's
what i accomplished
yeah it seems like you you you ventured
into that world of
sort of that gang mentality and then you
say here in the book i began to drift
away from the gang when members started
stealing stereos and using guns
i knew they were on a path that would
take them nowhere fast and i was much
more interested in jujitsu
surfing and girls than a life of crime
although i was rebellious and did things
that my dad didn't agree with i never
stopped competing and never stopped
winning
in his eyes that made me special it was
about this time that i began to train
with my brother holes
up to this point alia was my teacher
whether he was surfing
training fighting riding horses hang
gliding or chasing girls
holes was constantly in motion he was
fast technical
and always pushed me to train harder and
achieve
more training with holes was essentially
fighting he reinforced what elio had
taught me
[ __ ] points [ __ ] judges win by
submission
or not at all i began to improve quickly
under holes and alia was not surprised
i wasn't stubborn and never choked under
pressure
now the expectations for me were both
from holes and my dad and they were
extremely
high how many hours a day were you
training with holes at this time
uh at least four hours at least two
hours in the in the morning
or or in like in the early afternoon for
classes and
and then at the training at night so i
was
always at the school you know i was
never being too much
a good student you know so i get any
excuse to stay away from school and
stay at the academy or at the beach but
you know it was a good training very fun
how much time would you spend
sparring how much time would you spend
drilling how much time would you spend
creating new stuff normally the class
follows up with a sequence of drilling
learning some techniques some drills and
after the free
the free sparring so i follow the
protocols of the class
and i always going to learn something
training something or grab some
improving some kind of technique and
also the practice afterwards so i just
follow the program of
every class did you find yourself
and holes especially as holes as
bringing in
[ __ ] and and wrestling would you have
to break stuff down
and and kind of adapt it into jiu jitsu
do you remember doing that kind of thing
i remember holes showing the techniques
and we immediately because
he also have the eye for what's good for
us or not i was not learning from a
wrestling
teacher i was teaching i was learning
from a guy who learns wrestling
but he's a jiu-jitsu teacher and try to
favor us with
the best of it so things he may learn
and he didn't like it he'd not even show
us
he just showed the things we are related
to if the guy grabbed you here on the so
you do that so
i was just follow up his his lead on
what i should use from wrestling what i
should use from
[ __ ] what i should use from judo some
techniques in judo are suicidal
techniques
and puru after the troll you get caught
in a bad position so
you don't want to do those those
techniques so basically i was not there
to learn judo
i was actually learning a efficient way
to take people down with judo
but for jitsu so was that all the
preparation the techniques are kind of
slightly different than
being just a judo practitioner yeah i
was
i was lucky uh my my son when he
wrestled
he had a wrestling coach that started
working with his wrestling team that was
a jujitsu guy too
and so he could tell him hey do this
like hey this is like a sweep hey this
is like a scissor sweep
he would be able to coach him to wrestle
using jiu jitsu
with wrestling can relate much better
yeah yeah that's nice